welcome to this video playing mala feet
92 okay the other coin doing for some
variety who is playing the this is
called the hunt variation going for I
don't I don't know it anyway let's just
be six some sort of combination of be
six taking is probably right may be
taking us better now we can take on d5
and now and this is a bit bit of a bad
structure the double pants really make
the bishop on c8 being a slightly
problematic piece
okay well I have to shoot a six now at
least you know his premier worry but
this should be fun
okay let's let's grab the chance to get
rid of the somewhat problematic piece on
c8 okay well you see him he's going for
a forum on f1 go and play and fight him
I cannot allow him to play a five and if
he's if he takes now he's really
suffering from structural problems with
the follow especially and if he not if
he's not taking I have a night scene 726
this is actually quite nice the night
getting to its best possible square this
position
well besides if all he's writing the
main names oh blockade yeah this is this
is quite division type of position
that's true
Queen a4 maybe I'm getting rid of the
Queen's Queen b6 rook b8 wins the Queen
so maybe maybe b5 before me
mmm G for me I must be cautious I have
all the pieces on the Queen side yes
that comes ok let's go back just just
back I need I need some defense
I was just recognizing that I was
starting to put everything here on the
on the Queen side and it's it's quite
fortunate that his piece is the Queen on
c3 the knight and the bishop and not
really
in in good positions to to attack my
king so yeah wait-wait-wait-wait-wait
one of g6 this is actually quite good
yeah provoking him into that and now h4
h5 s takes takes really no while to be
dangerous now I can switch back to the
Queen side I'd like to play rook b8 and
before Wow yeah I'll take that
getting the Queen M getting night
against Bishop p.m. certainly good
intention look a for okayed just put
everything on the a file and try to
infiltrate yeah look a one
hmm I don't know I would have broke
every fluke is 3
yeah
yeah Ruka one just look p3
now I'm really controlling the fr and
the next next step I'm controlling the
fr but I'm blundering McQueen don't tell
me I'm blundering the Queen come on it's
amazing I mean what what the heck why
does completely outplayed we're really
completely and I just give away the
Queen you know
unbelievable unbelievable chuckling just
play like an idiot
and this was completely mean I'm
completely dominating night against
Bishop FZ a file with precise played
black is winning easily and I'm just
giving it away like a complete [ __ ]
well okay I can I can play a couple of
more simply because the position is so
close that maybe with some help I can I
can continue of course it's lost yeah
but you never know
he's got a wide open position if I
manage to let say double-under on the
second-ranked or something then there's
even a game
now this bishop see one
yeah this is a good move keep some stuff
protected
yeah I can I can also resign but I was
empty too disappointed I have to do that
I mean this was such a nice position
it's still it's the very closed but
white white should should certainly win
I still try try for a bit
you never know you can just take it on
have fun
and well now I can I can actually go to
the H file and now it sounds crazy but
this isn't so easy anymore Bishop takes
rook f8 and I got rook f8 to f5 aruch H
rook h8 to h5 to g5 this is the game
again I can't believe it
at least it's it's not completely
completely easy ok maybe I should I
should I should go here he cannot he
cannot infiltrate so easily
let's go here maybe if I go rook h5 his
his I am chatting with that Knight e4
maybe even
yeah why not Bishop g5 I go King e6
check I can't believe this
I blunder the whole Queen and it's still
a game f3 yeah f3 I mean this is this is
this is probably probably completely
turning to my favor here
check me know I'm wondering to make one
no no what the game what a game I hope
your ears are still intact after this
cry ah I can't believe it I really can't
believe this
I'm a queen down and I'm getting a
winning position again and then I'm
blundering to meet in one I mean ah King
f7 by the way is winning rook f4h form
it and he has no way to prevent it
absolutely no way yeah whatever I mean
even any move I mean any move not
allowing a mate it's just good for black
because everything's protected I have
the Jeep on and he's full of weaknesses
unbelievable unbelievable game
yeah I need a break I really need a
break